[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي العيال اختيار استهلها بابرز
العلوي
بخسائر كبيره خطا مهندس صيانه ورق تعطل
نظام اشعارات الطيران في الولايات المتحده
اكمل كراش
مجلس النواب يدعو للتحقيق معه
الشعورنا لا يوصف والحمد لله يعني تمت
العمليه بنجاح والله
العراقيه علي وع
مر
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من الولايات المتحده اذا
افادت شبكه اي بي سي نيوز الامريكيه ان
خطا مهندس صيانه وراء تعطل نظام اشعارات
الطيران في الولايات المتحده امس وذكرت
الشبكه نقل عن مسؤولين امريكا
ما ادى الى تعطل النظام واشار المسؤولي
لان العطل الذي اصاب حركه الطيران تسبب
بخسائر كبيره
منه
حسين الطود مراسل العربيه حسين يعني على
ما يبدو حركه الطيران عاده الى طبيعتها
حركه المسافرين طبعا عادت الى طبيعتها كيف
هي الصوره من هناك ما الجديد بهذا الملف
ظه اليوم ان حركه الطيران طبيعيه جدا
وكذلك حركه المسافرين حتى اذا نظرنا الى
هذه اللوائح الموجوده هنا امامنا لا نرى
تاخيرات ولا تاجيل ما عدا همم في هذا
المطار هناك همم تاخيرا لرحلتين متجهتين
الى كندا باقي
الرحلات هي على موعدها همم بشكل طبيعي حتى
بالنسبه
للمسافرين اذا نظرنا الى حركه المسافرين
همم الحركه عاديه لا يوجد تاخير التقيت
اليوم ببعض المسافرين الذين اجلوا رحلاتهم
من امبارح الى اليوم ولكن عندما سالتهم هل
لواجه مشكله اليوم قالوا ان الامور بثلاثه
لا توجد اي مشكله حتى الان يواجهونها طبعا
كان هناك تخوف من ان همم يكون همم
لقرار البارحه بيوقف همم تحليق الطائرات
الامريكيه في الاجواء الامريكيه ان يكون
له تداعيات على اليوم
تستمر المشكله اليوم ولكن شركات الطيران
الامريكيه الكبرى مثل دلتا ام امريكان
ايرلاين ويونايتد تعهدوا بان يتخذوا
الاجراءات اللازمه لتيس لتيسير وتيسير
الحركه بشكل طبيعي وهذا على ما يبدو قد
نجحوا به لا نرى ازدحامات كبيره كما حدث
خلال عطله نهايه راس السنه عندما كان هناك
ازدحام في المطارات والغالي طائرات كثيره
في همم على مدار ايام هذا في اقل من 24
ساعه تم تدرك الموقف ولكن ما جرى همم بكل
هذه الامور سلطت الان همم هنا في الولايات
المتحده على موضوع تحديث
اجهزه
وانظمه همم دائره اداره الطيران
الفيدراليه الامريكيه الان يتساءلون متى
سيتم تحديث هذه البرامج لاسيه ان الرئيس
همم همم كان وقع في شهر نوفمبر من عام
2021 على قانون
بنيه التحديث التحتيه تحديث البنيه
التحتيه وخصص اربع مليارات دولار لتحديد
البنيه تحتيه للمطارات الامريكيه و مليار
دولار لتحديث اجهزه ومعدات همم اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه الان يسال اين ذهبت
هذه الاموال طبعا البعض يقول بان هذه
الاموال حتى تصرف هي تحتاج الى مزيد من
الوقت ولكن الاسئله همم
تتزايد ولا سيما من قبل الجمهورينا في
الكونغرس الامريكي ان يكون المتحدث عن
مجلس النواب او مجلس الشيوخ همم هناك
دعوات الان الى تعيين رئيس لاداره همم
الطيران الفيدرالي لان حتى الان لا يوجد
على راسها همم رئيس تنفيذي لها هناك من
يقول خاصه من الجمهوريين بان الوقت قد حان
وبانه مرشح الرئيس واشنطن همم هو غير مؤهل
تادرس قال ان هذه الاداره الاداره مهمه
بحاجه الى رئيس له علم ودرايه بموضوع
سلامه الطيران وليس ايام مرشح عادي طبعا
هو حتى الان لم لم ااه تعقد اي جلسه
استماع
لمرشح الرئيس بايدن الى الذي قلنا اسمه
وهو فل واشنطن هناك تاجيل من قبل الديمقرا
عفوا الجمهوريين الامور كما قلنا لها ايضا
تداعيات سياسيه همم هناك انتخابات كثيره
توجهها الرئيس
وزير النقل
حسين يعني اليوم يتم استغلال الموضوع
بالسياسه وطبعا الملف اليوم داخل الولايات
المتحده يتم تاسيس نظرا لاحتدام المعركه
بين الحزبين ولكن بالموضوع التقنيه
الخبراء بالامس كانوا يقولون بانه لا شيء
ممكن ان يمنع من ان يتم تكرار ما حصل همم
بالامس من تعطل ومن عطل على مستوى كل
الولايات المتحده هل سيكون اتخاذ اي تبديل
ميراث جديه بهذا الموضوع
ليال عندما تحدث البارحه وزير النقل بجاج
قال اولا هو دافع عن قرار اداره الطيران
الفيدرالي بانها اوقفت جميع الرحلات وقال
ذلك اجراء احترازي كي لا يحدث هناك وقوع
حوادث عفوا ولكن في الوقت نفسه قال ان هذا
الامر يجب ان لا يتكرر هو اخذ على عاتقه
هذا الامر هذا السبب الان تسلط كما قلنا
على موضوع تحديث اجهزه اداره النقل
والطيران اجهزه الكمبيوتر اجهزه البرامج
الضوء والصلاه على هذه المساله همم
بالدجاج وزير النقل حول هذا الموضوع وحول
اهليته اصلا هي كي يكون همم وزيرا للنقل
هذه هنا بالفعل هذا سؤال مطروح هناك تخوف
مثل هذه المشكله وان همم تتسبب ايضا بمزيد
من الخسائر هذا الامر يترتب خسائر
تعويضات المسافرين الذين تم الغاء رحلاتهم
يعني هناك خسائر ماليه كبيره سبحان من
جميع الان ان يتدادا شكرا لك حسين الطود
مراسل العربيه حدثنا من مطار رونالدو
[موسيقى]
مقراطيه تاره اخرى البيت الابيض اعلن
العثور على وثائقي مصنفه على انها سريه
تعود الى الفتره التي تولى فيها الجبايدر
منصبه نائب الرئيس في منزله بمقاطعه
وذلك بعد ايام من الاعلان عن العثور على
وثائقها حساسه في مركز للابحاث فيه وعن
الشيطان وهو ما دفع اسم مجلس النواب
الامريكي
الى استغلال الموقف بمطلبات الكونجرس
بتحقيق مع بيضا بشان تلك الوثائق السريه
اعتقد ان الكونجرس يجب ان يحقق بقضيه
الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها في منزل
ومكتب الرئيس هو شخص بقي في الحكومه لاكثر
من 40 عاما هذا الشخص كان حريصا جدا على
النظر بامر وثائق الرئيس ترامب والان نجد
انه عندما كان نائبا للرئيس احتفظ بالعديد
من الوثائق السريه باماكن مختلفه
الوثائق السريه التي اكتشفت صدفه باحد
مكاتب بيدن حين كان نائبا لاوما استدعت
المزيد من عمليات التفتيش البحث الاولي
كشف حزمه جديده سريه كذلك في مكان منفصل
عن مكتب واشنطن الذي استخدمه بايدا بعد
مغادره ادارته ومغادره اداره اوباما طبعا
مساعد الرئيس الامريكي اكتشفوا هذه
المجموعه خلال بحث وصف بالشامل في مواقع
اخرى استخدامها الرئيس ووفقا لشبكه
بي سي نيوز الامريكيه لم يتضح على الفور
مستوى تصنيف الوثائق الاضافيه وعددها
وموقعها الدقيق كما لم يتضح تاريخ
اكتشافها او عدد ممتلكات بيدن التي فتشت
وما اذا كان البحث عن مواد سريه اخرى قد
اكتمل بيضمن فوجئ بالوثائق المكتشفه واكد
عدم معرفته بما هو موجود داخل هذه الوثائق
حسب قوله فيما رفض متحدثون باسمي وزاره
العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي والبيت
الابيض التعليق على هذا الامر اختلاف
رئيسي بين قضيتين ترامب وبعد اذن يركز
عليه اعلام امريكي مع استبعاد تحول وثائق
الاخير لمساله جنائيه مماثله
الى تعاون محامي بيدن مع وزاره العدل
وتسليم الوثائق توعيه وبسرعه لاداره
المحفوظات الوطنيه
لجهود السعاده المواد هذا وستعلق وزاره
العدل بعد قليل على هذه الوثائق فاكون
معنا
[موسيقى]
قليل
ايام في السيطره الروسيه الكامله على
فوليدار ويؤكد استمرار المعارك هناك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دعا احد قاده الجيش
الاوكراني في جبهه باخموت قوته الى
التراجع والانسحاب في حال استمرار تكبد
الخسائر بحجم كبير على تلك الجبهه وفقا
لما افادت به صحيفه
وباخر مستجدات الملف الاوكراني حيث نقلت
عن احد قاده القوات الاوكرانيه ان خسائر
اوكرانيا تفوق خسائر الروس على جبهات
الشرق هذا ولفت الصحيفه الى تفضيل
مسؤولينا اوكرانيين وغربيين مغادره القوات
الاوكرانيه لباخموس والانتقالي لخطي دفاعا
شديد على خلفيه الخسائر التي تكبدتها
مؤخرا لكن الرئيس يشدد بدوره على انه على
انه جيش يدافع ويقاوم داخل قائلا انك تدعم
عمليات الدفاع عن بخ متواصل لدار بكل ما
يلزم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في اخر التطورات على الارض لابد
ان نبدا
بالملابس
روايتين متناقدتين بين كل من فاجنر بهذه
المنطقه التي تدور فيها المعارك منذ اوائل
الاسبوع فاقدر تقول بانها حكمت السيطره
على سوليدار بينما وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لم توضع هذا الامر وايضا اكياف نفته نفيا
قاطعا وهذا ما سيشرحه الزميل رائد الاخضر
لاحقا بالنقل المباشر طبعا سوليدار اليوم
ما زالت هناك معارك فيها وتحديدا في
الجبهه الغربيه حيث استخدمت اكياس بعض
التعزيزات الى هذه الجبهه تحديدا في سوليد
اما باخ موت بما ان السيطره لم تحتم على
سوليدار وبالتالي هذه المنطقه همم التي
اذا ما سقطت سوليدار يمكن للقوات الروسيه
احكام السيطره عليها وطبعا اا تطويقه من
كل الجبهات ما يسمح لها باحكام السيطره
عليها ولكن حتى الساعه يمكن القول بان
بخمط ما زالت خارج السيطره الروسيه بالملف
ايضا الاخر على الارض مدينه دنياسك
بالساعات الاخيره هناك قصف اوكراني كثير
لدنياس طبعا البعض وصفوا بقصف
الانتقامي لما يحصل بالمناطق الاخرى
وتحديدا في سوليدات حيث قصفت الدفاع
الاوكرانيه 90 صاروخا بالاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه مما ادى الى مقتل شخص واصابه
اثنين اخرين بجروح وطبعا قصص البنيه
التحتيه
والمرافق السكنيه بهذه المنطقه اذا كانت
هذه اخر التطورات على الارض
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال المتحدث باسمي وزارات الدفاع الروسيه
ان الهجمات العسكريه الروسيه على دنياز
خلفت خسائر الجانب الاوكراني لا يمكن
تعويضها والتي جاء في نتائجها مقتل 70
فردا من الجيش الاكراني
القوات الروسيه نتيجه الضربه الجويه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من دنياز قراءه
الاخبار مراسل العربيه وايضا من كياب
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه سابدا معك رائد
بما انك على الارض هناك الروايتين
المتناقضتين اللتان يعني كنا نتحدث عنهما
بين كل من فاكتور ووزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وايضا طبعا ان في الاوكراني كيف يمكن
تفسير
مساء الخير ليان
في مساله التباين في التصريحات ما بين
الطرفين القوات التي تقاتل في سندار مثل
قواتنا القوات الشعبيه قوات الناس والقوات
لابد من الاشاره الى القصف العنيف التي
الذي تشهده مدينه سوليدار هنا حيث بالفعل
منذ صباح الباكر لم يتوقف القصص كانت يعني
حصيله القتلى والاصابات قتيل وعده اصابات
خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه واليوم قتيل اخر
اضافه الى بعض الاصابات والدمار في البناء
التحتيه همم ربما ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقصف المدينه بشكل الانتقام لما يحصل من
تقدم للقوات الروسيه في محور سوليدار
الدفاع الروسيه همم يعني همم اخرج تقريبا
اص
يوم امس هو همم السيطره على المناطق
الشماليه والشرقيه من المدينه وان معارك
ما زالت ضاريه في وسط المدينه وفي محاور
مختلفه لكن اا قائد قوات باقربه السلطات
المحليه هنا في
دنيتك يعني الرئيس او الفان باعمال
الرئاسه
يؤكد سيطره الجيش الروسي وكل القوات
الروسيه على كامل حدود مدينه سيدار وانها
اعمال تنظيف او تطهير كما يصفونها تجري في
جيوب المدينه المختلفه لابد من الاشاره
ايضا كما قاله قائد قوات بانر بان اكثر من
خمسمائه اوكرانيا رفضوا الاستسلام وتم
قتلهم وتصفيتهم همم بالفعل المعارك ما زال
الضاريه
وهنا الى اندادات تصل الى المناطق الغربيه
بينما تقصف المدفعيه والاله العسكريه
الثقيله والمقاتلات الروسيه مناطق في غرب
مدينه سندار وتقصف الامدادات الطريق
السريع الذي يوصل الامدادات كما انها قصفت
مركز للاتصالات مركز قياده يوصل الجبهات
مع قواعد اتصاليه
وحذيفه سانتقل الى حذيفه ولكن بعد هذا
العاجل المشاهدين كما نتابع الان على
الشاشه العدل الامريكيه تعيين مستشار
لتحقيق بقضيه الوفاق السريه التي عثر
عليها بمنزل اذا الان هذه الصور المباشره
من وزاره العدل في واشنطن طبعا بايطار
تطور مسار قضيه همم الوثائق التي عثرت
عليها بمكتب الرئيس حينما كان نائب رئيس
ضمن اداره اوباما طبعا يعني هذه الوثائق
تاتي بتوقيت حساس توقيت سياسي حساس لبيض
واداراته على ابواب الانتخابات وطبعا على
بعد يعني كل الملفات التي يحاول
الجمهوريين التصويب بها على الرئيس
واداراته بالعوده الى الميدان والى
الزملاء الان اليك همم حذيفه حذيفه ايضا
يعني
مواذاه الروايتين المتناقدتين بين فاجنر
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه هناك روايه اوكرانيه
في تماما سيطرت همم القوات الروسيه على
وليد ما الذي يحصل هناك
نعم مساء الخير ليال لكي وليزامير رائد في
الحقيقه بخصوص سوليدار البيان الرسمي الذي
صدر من وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاتل على
سردار ولا يوجد اي سيطره روسيه على هذه
المدينه كذلك صرحت نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان ميلر وقالت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تتخلى عن مواقعها والقتال
يدور حول السبدار ولا يجب الالتفات الى
الدعايه الروسيه ولكن ايضا همم يعني
الرسائل الغير رسميه التي اتت من هناك من
مدينه الاداريه من الجنود ومن الضباط
الذين يقاتلون في مدينه في دار شاهدنا
عشرات الفيديوهات التي نشرها الجنود
الاخرانيين في سوليدار التي اتحدث فيها عن
الوضع قالوا انه يعني الرسائل يعني اهم
هذه الرسائل كانت انه لا داعي للذعر
المدينه ما زال تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه هنالك القتال شوارع في المدينه
والقوات الاوكرانيه لا تتخلى عن مواقعها
هجمات الروسي بالموجات كان الموجات تستمر
الموجات الهجوم تستمر من قبل القوات
الروسيه ولكنها
تصطاد بالدفاعات الاوكرانيه هذا الوضع من
الجانب الاوكراني وكان الرسمي او من
الجانب الجنود يعني الجانب الغير رسمي
وطبعا هي عن طريق هذه الرسائل المصوره من
قبل الجنود الاوكرانيين في تلك المدينه
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من استهداف روسيا المستمر
للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه الاوكرانيه كافح
عمال الطاقه لاصلاح الاضرار بعد كل ضربه
روسيه في محاوله لمنع اوكرانيا من
الانغماس في الظلام الدامس في ظل شتاء
خالص
الكهربائيه خلال النهار وبدانا التسخين
وصلنا للحمل المطلوب اذا توقفت الوحدات
الكهربائيه تنجد انفسنا دون دفء وضوء
جبهه ممثله مقابله للجنود الاوكرانيين
يقود المواجهه فيها مهندسون وعمال صيانه
الكهرباء
تاتي حمايه شبكه الكهرباء في اوكرانيا مع
الاستهداف الروسيه المتكرر لها وفقه صحيفه
الامريكيه ساعات طويله محفوفه بالمخاطر
تمضيها طواقم ما سمي بكتيبه الكهرباء
وتامين الاناره والتدفئه لملايين
الاوكرانيين عناصرها يواجهون خطر القصف
المستمر في يتواجهون للملائكه عندما تنطلق
تحضيرات الغارات الجويه او يحتمون حيثما
حيثما ام كانهم تحت الجسور مثلا اما
العمال الموجودون قرب الخطوط الاماميه
فيرتدون دروعا واقيه مع الحاجه الى
مرافقنا عسكريين وقد لقيا ما لا يقل عن 10
اشخاص نصرعهم اثناء العمل منذ اكتوبر
الماضي في ما عدا بعض العمال من التقاعد
يحل محل المئات الذين التحقوا بالقوات
المسلحه خطط الصيانه تشمل فرقا مكونه من
تسعه افراد للعمل في ثلاث
مناوبات على مدار 24 ساعه هذه الفرق تفكك
المحاولات المدمره او المعطله وتستبدلها
غير انه المحولات عفوا غير ان البلاد
تنفذ من هذه او تنفذ من هذه الاجزاء
المطلوبه علما بان اوروبا والولايات
المتحده تستخدم معدات تعمل وفقا لمعايير
مختلفه ما يزيد طبعا صعوبه التقديم بدائل
[موسيقى]
عروض بالدبابات الغربيه انهامرت على
القياده الاوكرانيه خلال الايام الماضيه
من فرنسا والولايات المتحده والمانيا
دبابات وصفت بالخفيفه اثار التساؤلات حول
مدى تاثيرها بالحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
وان كانت ستصب بخانه زياده العقبات
اللوجستيه خبراء عسكريون اكدوا انما وعدت
به وبتقديمه البلدان الثلاثه اي اي ام اكس
دبابات على الاطلاق بل المركبات قتاليه
مدرعه اصغر واخف واسرع حركه من ذبابات
القتال الرئيسيه ومزوده بمدفع عن رئيسه
بعيار اصغر من اي دبابه عاديه واقل تدري
عنها الميزه الرئيسيه للدبابات الخفيفه
استخدامها بمختلف الادوار بما فيها نقل
القوات واثناد المشاه والدعم في الحرب ضد
الدروع والاستطلاع طبعا هذه المركبات
مشاهدينا قادره على قلب موازين القوى وفق
خبراء تكتيكيا ستوفر قدره اكبر على التحرك
والسرعه والحمايه في دعم عمليات المشاه
كما انها اسرع استجابه في المواقف
المتغيره اي التكيف مع طبيعه الاراضي او
الاحوال الجويه ولديها امكانيه اطلاق
النار عن بعد ما يتيح هزيمه الدبابات
الروسيه بالصواريخ المضاده للدبابات اما
على المستوى العملات فاثبت الجيش
الاوكراني انه ينفذ عمليات الاسلحه
المشتركه بكفاءه غير ان هذه الانظمه
ستحتاج طبعا الى اسابيع من التدريب على
تشغيلها وصيانتها وقد تحت اج- لتعديلات
وبالتالي انشاء مسار لوجستي لتوفير قطع
الغيار والاصلاحات كما ستتسبب بتحديات
لوجيسيه كبيره قد تترافق مع احتماليه
تصعيد الصراع وتوسيعه بين روسيا والغرب
بحسب الخبراء
[موسيقى]
الى الملف السوري التركي حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه التركي انه قد يلتقي بنظيره
السوري فيصل المقداد في اوائل فبراير
نافيا تقارير التي تفيد بانهما قد يجتمعان
الاسبوع المقبل واضاف جوش اوغلو ان انقر
اعلنت قبل ذلك ان هناك بعض المقترحات بشان
لقاء الاسبوع المقبل لكنها لا تناسب
الجانب التركي في ما لم يعلق الجانب
الروسي او نظام الاسد على الاعلان التركي
هذا حتى هذه الساعه طبعا لانه الجانبيه
قال الرئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد ان
اللقاءات مع تركيا يجب ان تنطلق او من
مبدا انهاء الوجود التركي على الاراضي
السوريه جاء ذلك بعد لقاء الاسد مع
المبعوث الخاص للرئيس الروسيب لازم يربوطن
والوفد المرافق له بدمشق
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول جواد جوك
المحلل السياسي استاذ جواد يعني تاجيل هذا
اللقاء هل هو ضغط امريكي ام الخلاف على
التفاصيل خصوصا ان الشروط وبنود الشروط هي
ليست التفصيليه وهي كثيره ام انه الاثنين
معا
كلا الاحتمالين موجوده يعني هناك
مقترحات امريكيه
للتفاوض بين تركيا وقوات قصد
وايضا يعني حلوا يعني مشاكل للامن القومي
التركي عبر اللقاء مع قوات خاصه ومن جهه
اخرى نعم هناك خلافات بين تركيا وسوريا
واضح جدا لكن بشكل واخر الجانبان التركي
والسوري يريدان ان يكون هناك تواصل مباشر
بين دمشق وانقره دون تدخل من
الجوانب الاخرى من العواصم الاخرى بصراحه
يعني انا معانا سوريا وتركيا من هذا التوت
ومن هذا الحرب الدائره في الحدود وغير ذلك
جدول زمني للانسحاب التركي عدم دعم
المعارضه موضوع الاكراد موضوع ادلب وموضوع
اللاجئين اي من هذه المواضيع اليوم هو حجر
العقبه الاساس والحل السياسي طبعا
طبعا الخطبه الاولى تعيين السفيرين من
الجانب الى التركي والسوري الى العواصب
لكن راينا يعني الحكومه التركيه بطيئه جدا
في ان يكون عوده العلاقات ان تكون عمليا
مثلا عودته العلاقات مع مصر كم مره
اقترحوا ان تكون هناك خطوات عمليه تركيا
كانت بطيئه جدا بهذا الخصوص كان البلد ما
الحكومه تنتظر الانتخابات القادمه بصراحه
انا لا انتظر اتوقع خطوات عمليه لما قبل
الانتخابات في الشهر الخامس اذا فازت
الحكومه التركيه فتكون يدها قويه في
المفاوضات مع الجانب السوري لكن اذا فازت
المعارضه طبعا تتغير جميع المعادلات في
المنطقه اليوم يعني هناك مؤشرات على
احتماليه فوز المعارضه اذا ما اتحدت بشكل
قوي وان هذه الانتخابات المقبله هي بمثابه
استفتاء على حزب العداله والتنميه هل يعني
تاخير
توافق مع سوريا
سيستغل ستستغل المعارضه اليوم للتصويب على
اردوغان بملف اللاجئين
طبعا ملف اللاجئين من احد الملفات القويه
والورق القويه بيد المعارضه بعد ورقه
الاقتصاد والتضخم في تركيا بصراحه الحكومه
كانت سياستها تجاه سوريا
احد اسبابها تواجد اللاجئين بهذه الاعداد
الحائله في البلد بصراحه اكثر من اربع
ملايين والحال لا يستمر بهذا الشكل معروف
ولهذا السبب لابد ان يكون هناك حل جذري
لهذه القضيه وهذا طريقها التواصل مع دمشق
بشكل مباشر
حدثنا من اسطنبول
نقعد مشاهدينا ونستمع لوزير العدل
الامريكي الذي اكد تعيين مستشار خاص
للتحقيق بمساله وجود وثائق سريه في مقرات
للرئيس ايضا
انه تم تعيين عضو من كل الحزب من كل
الحزبين جونكارد
الذي قام بتحقيق الاولي في هذه المساله
التي ساصفها امامكم اليوم في مساء الرابع
من نوفمبر 20 22
مكتب مفتش العامه للارشيف لا ال ال
البيت الابيض قال لهم همم هناك ملفات في
ال- اا ارشيف هي ملفات خاصه
للرئاسه وهذا المكتب
لم يخون له
تلك الملفات
السريه وبالتالي تم تقييم من الافراي وفقا
للبروتوكولات المعتمده لدراسه هذه
المعلومات سريه ان كانت فيها تجاوز
للقوانين الفيدراليه وفي الرابعه عشر من
نوفمبر كان هناك وفقا للقوانين انا
اطلقته تحقيقا مبدئيا
لاطلعهم بقراري اذا كان هناك
بخبرته انه سيقوم بهذه العمليه بمهنيه
واحتراف وبسرعه في ديسمبر 20 همم السيد
قال ان هناك همم ملفات
حتى ارشيفيه كانت في جرى مراهقاب همم بيت
الرئيس سبايدر في دالاس
كانت من الفتره التي كان فيها في منصب
نائب الرئيس
وفي الخامس من يناير 23 السيد العرش نتائج
تحقيقه الاوليه
البلبيسي مراسيله العربيه ناديه كيف يمكن
قراءه هذا التعيين وهذا الاعلان
هذا يعني بان الموضوع ليس كما وصفه الرئيس
او البيت الابيض بانها وثائق كانت موجوده
في مكتب كانتابعه بعيدا عندما كان نائب
للرئيس ايضا يتهم البيت الابيض الان بان
هناك اخفاء للمعلومات يعني ما سمعناه قبل
قليل من مارجال وزير العدل قال بانه ايضا
في ديسمبر في الرابع من ديسمبر كان هناك
لديه معلومات عن وجود وثائق اخرى سريه كان
الرئيس يحتفظ بها في كراج لبيته في اول من
تنفي ولايه دلوعه وبالتالي البيت الابيض
بالامس كانت هناك مساء عليك في الايجاز
الصحفي عن ما تعرف هل البيت الابيض اخفى
هذه المعلومات ام لا وطبعا هذا البيت
الابيض يميز نفسه بانه يتمتع بالشفافيه
وبانه همم سيحاسب اي شخص يخفي معلومات الى
اخره حتى رئيس نفسه كان يقول عندما تعلق
الامر بالرئيس ترامب بانه غير مقبول على
الاطلاق بانه امر لا يصدق ان حافظ الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ووثائق سوريه وهاو
الرئيس يكشف الان من قبل وزاره العدل بان
هناك ايضا وثائق سريه جديده ليس فقط في
المكان الذي تحدث عنه قبل يومين وهو مكتب
قريب من مبنى الكابتل لكن الان في بيته في
منزله في ولايه ديلور وبالتالي هناك
مسائلات كثيره اضطرت وزير العدل الى تعيين
محققات لنعرف من ما هي الوسائل هذه
الوثائق ما محتوى هذه الوثائق هل هي
بالفعل السريه او في غايه السريه من هي
الدول التي تحدث عنها همم بالسابق طبعا
احد همم المستشارين الذي قال او المحامين
للرئيس الذي قال بانها ربما لديهم معلومات
عن المملكه المتحده لكن كيف احتفظ الرئيس
بها طوال هذا الوقت هذا هو السؤال همم
ناديه يعني هل نحن اليوم امام مسار مماثل
لقضيه الرئيس ترامب
يعني البيت الابيض يقول لا لان هناك
الكثير من وجهه الاختلاف اولا البيت
الابيض يقول بانه تعاون مع المحققين بمجرد
اكتشاف اول دفعه من هذه الوثائق قام
باعلام وزاره العدل والاف بي اي طبعا
وبانو طواعي يا سلام كل هذه الاوراق بينما
العسكري مع الرئيس ترامب عاد على ان كانت
هناك مداهمه طلب رسمي من الاف بي اي
بمداهمه طبعا الوثائق التي كانت في حوزه
الرئيس ترامب عددها ايضا هو غير متكافئ
نتحدث ربما عن عشرات بينما كان بالمئات
بالنسبه للرئيس همم ترامب ايضا التهمه
ترامب بعنقله مجرى العداله لانه رفض
التعاون مع المحققين الى غيره لكن بغض
النظر هذه اكيد سيكون هناك تداعيات سياسيه
للرئيس بايدن بالنسبه لهذه الوثائق واهم
هو ازواجيه المعايير من البيت الابيض يضع
نفسه في مكان ارفع واعلى بالنسبه للاحتفاظ
تمام بالشفافيه ان هذا الامر ليس كذلك
يعني تسقط على راس الرئيس فايدم بالامس
موضوع تعطل الطيران داخل الولايات المتحده
اليوم تعيين محقق بقضيه الوثائق ووثائق
واثر عليها بكراج يعني بكراج منزل بايظن
كل هذا هل سيؤثر على عمل السنتين المقبلين
طبعا حسب ما توصفه او تتحدث عنه الاوساط
الامريكيه
اكيد سيسمم سيتم استغلاله سياسيا من قبل
الجمهوريين كنا قد تحدثنا قبل يومين عن
كيف المقاس قبل قليل كان له اول مؤتمر
صحفي كرئيس المجلس وبالفعل تحدث عن هذا
وقال بانه الامريكيون بشكل عام يقيمون
الشفافيه ومنطق العداله وعدم ازدواجيه
المعايير لما تتطبق على الرئيس ترامب ولا
تطبق على الرئيس مثلا
خلال العامين القديمين سنسمع الكثير
بالنسبه لهذا لهذه القضيه بالتحديد وستكون
ربما عامل سيؤثر في قرار الرئيس وبعدين
اذا كان سيترشح او لا خصوصا اذا كان لها
تدعيه سياسيه وجلسات استماع في الكونجرس
الديمقراطيين نفسهم يعني قاده الديمقراطيه
سيقررون اذا كان رئيس سبايدر مان هو
الانسب لتمثيلهم في الانتخابات القادمه
العربيه حدثنا
مشاهدينا التاسعه المستمره وفيها بعد قليل
العربيه تلتقي استاذ جامعي مزق شهاداته
احتجاجا على قرار طالبان بحظري تعليم
النساء بافغانستان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا حذرات منظمه
العفو الدوليه من احتماليه اعدام المتظاهر
الايرانيه المعتقل محمد بادلو واضافت ان
السلطات الايرانيه اجبرته وهو البالغ من
العمر 23 عاما على الاعتراف بدهس قوات امن
بالسياره تحت التعذيب
في الملف اعدام المتظاهرين ايضا تشير
التقارير الحقوقيه الى استمرار الممارسات
القمعيه للنظام بما في ذلك اختطاف الاطفال
واصدار احكام قاسيه بحق المحتاجين
بالاضافه الى تعرض المتظاهرين المسجونين
لتعذيب كما استهدف القمع بشكل رئيسي
الطلاب الذين شكلوا نواه الاحتجاجات على
مدار الاشهر الماضيه حيث افاده المجلس
التنسيقي لنقابات المعلمين باعتقال الطالب
معيد حسيني البلاغ من العمر 17 عاما وتشير
التقارير ايضا الى ان المحكمه الثوريه في
محافظه ساري استدعت اربعه وعشرين طالبا من
جامعه
ومن بينهم 16 طالبا تم استدعائهم في يوم
واحد شملت حملات القمع مشاهدينا اساتذه
وصحافيون ايضا انتشرت نقابه الصحفيين
قائمه بالمعتقلين الذين بلغوا 30 صحفيه
مؤكده انهم ما زالوا رهن الاحتجاجات منذ
بدايه الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
الا وزير الدوله بوزاره الشؤون الخارجيه
البريطانيه امام البرلمان البريطانيا تدرس
تصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني كمنظمه
ارهابيه لكنها لم تتخذ بعد قرار نهائيا
بهذا الشان اقل خلال مناقشه للوضع في
ايران دعا خلالها بعض الاعضاء الى حضر
الحرس الثوري ساكون مخطئا اذا قدمت تكهنات
بشان نتيجه الدراسه التي تجريها الحكومه
في الوقت الراهن لهذه القضيه وهي دراسه
تجرى بجديه
[موسيقى]
من ايران الى جارتها افغانستان وبعد اغلاق
ابواب المدارس والجامعات امام الفتيات
وتعليق عمل النساء في المنظمات الدوليه
تضييق حركه طالبان المساحه المتاحه امام
النساء حيث امر حاكم اقليم جور الواقع وسط
البلاد مؤخرا مقاتلي الحركه بمنع النساء
من الخروج من المنازل في المدينه بدون
محرم وقالت مصادر في اقليم صحيفه افغانيها
محليه ان احمد شاه حاكم طالبان في الاقليم
عبر عن غضبه من تعليق بعض المنظمات
الاجنبيه لاعمالها بسبب القرارات الاخيره
لطالبان ضد النساء وقال ان المؤسسات
الاجنبيه غير صادقه مع شعب افغانستان حيث
دانا ما وصفه باستخدام كذا ريحه لهجوم
الغرب على بيئته هذا وامر شاه بعدم السماح
للمراه بالتجول في شوارع المدينه دون محرم
من الان فصاعدا ووجهها طبعا بتكثيف
الدوريات في المدينه لتوقيف النساء
المخالفات هنا نقلت صحيفه محليه عن سيده
بالمدينه تشتكي من القيود المتزايده التي
تفرضها حركه طالبان على النساء
وقالت انها علمت بالقرار من صاحب احد
المتاجر الذي دعاها للتسوق سريعا والعوده
للمنزل من دون ان تراها دوريات طالبان
الاسواق مشاهدينا باتت خاليه من النساء
فجاه بعد قرار منع التجوال من دون محرم
وهو ما اعتبرته ناشطات افغانيات بالانتهاك
لحقوقنا
[موسيقى]
وفي افغانستان ايضا تتوالى ردود الافعال
على قرار طالبان بمنع الفتيات من التعليم
في الجامعات والمعاهد العربيه التقد
بالاستاذ الذي مزق الوثائق التعليميه
تضامنا مع الفتيات الافغانيات
[موسيقى]
من الصعب جدا واذ مجهود العمر كله من
الشهادات والوثائق الاكاديميه لكن مشاعر
قويه دفعته الى اخذ هذا القرار الصعب كما
يقول اسماعيل مشعل الاستاذ الجامعي الذي
مزق شهاداته في برنامج متلفزن ردا على
قرار طالبانا بمنع الفتيات من
التعليميات الى ان استطيع واتمكن من
الكفاح الذي بداته من اجل سيدات اللواتي
يبلغ عددهن 20 مليون
فريد احمد من زملائي مشعل في العمليه
التعليميه استاذ جامعي لكنه قدم استقاله
من مهامه التعليميه في الجامعه ايضا يكافح
مع مشعل جنبا الى جنب لاسترجاع الحقوق
التعليميه المشروعه للفتيات
لن نرجع الى مهمتنا المقدسه مهمه التدريس
حتى تفتح جميع باب المدارس والمعاهد
والجامعات امام جميع الفتيات في جميع
افغانستان
اسماعيل مشعل يملك حاليا مدرسه ابتدائيه
ومعهدا وجامعه يقول انه عنتره جميع هذه
المشاريع التعليميه تضامنا مع الفتيات
الافغانيات ويشتغل في مؤسسته الخيريه التي
تقدم خدمات انسانيه
للمحتاجين في المجتمع الافغاني على اي حال
فان
الاستاذ نادما على تمزيقه شهادات لكن
صنيعه ياتي لوجه رساله لفظ لقرار منع
تعليم الفتيات وهو يعلم ان ما فعله لن
يثني طالبانا عن قرارها قبل هذه العربيه
كابول
[موسيقى]
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه حيث نجحت
عمليات فصل التوام السيامي العراقيه علي
وعمر بعد 11 ساعه بغرفه العمليات المشاركه
27 من الاستشاريين ولا اختصاصيين والكوادر
التمريضيه والفنيه وذلك بمستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي للاطفال في مدينه الملك عبد
العزيز الطبيه للحرس الوطني
توجيهات خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود وولي عهده
الان
اخبارنا الدكتور عبد الله رضيعه والفريق
الطبي كامل انه وضعهم مستقر والحمد لله
وانهم بصحه جيده وان شاء الله بس منتظرين
للافرقه وشكر جزيل الدكتور عبد الله
الربيع ولطاقم الطبي كاملا وشكري وامتناني
الى الملك
والى الملك سلمان والى ولي عهده الامين
محمد بن سلمان والى الشعب السعودي كاف
الذي تفاعل معنا شكرا جزيلا
مشاهدينا من مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي للاطفال بوزاره الحرس الوطني
بالرياض هاني صفيان مراسل العربيه هاني
يعني كيف يمكن الحديث عن وضع الطفلين علي
وعمر بعد نجاح عمليات الفصل وضعهم الصحي
وكل التفاصيل معك
نعم اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدي قناه العربيه
مره اخرى عمر وعلي هما حالتهما الصحيه
الان جيده بحسب حديث اكادر الطبيه الموجود
هنا في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وتحديدا في وزاره
التابع لوزاره الحرس الوطني طبعا هما في
تحت التخدير الان ما زال هذه غرفه همم علي
وهو الان يتم الاشراف عليهم من قبل كادر
الطبي وكذلك الغرفه المجاوره له وهي لغرفه
لعمر وايضا يتم مراقبه همم حاله عمر وعلي
من خلال الكادر الطبي وكذلك من خلال
التقنيات الحديثه الموفره هنا في المستشفى
ولكن بشكل طبي دقيق سوف نتحدث مع الدكتوره
هاله العالم وهي استشاريه عنايه مركزه
للاطفال تفضل لنا الدكتور ونتحدث اليوم عن
حاله الحاله الان لعمر وعلي او علي وعمر
خاصه في ظل وضعهما الان في حاله التخدير
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اللهم صل
وسلم وبارك على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
وسلم
حاله طفلين الحمد لله مستقره اا استلمنا
الطفل الطفلين
حوالي ثلاث ساعات
والمؤشرات الحيويه مطمئنه همم اي اختلاف
في المؤشرات الحيويه في اول ثلاثه ساعات
همم تعتبر طبيعيه ومقبوله ويتم التعامل مع
الارتفاع دقات القلب او ضغط الدم وكذا عن
طريق المراقبه وعن طريق همم اللي هو تظبيط
الادويه المناسبه الدكتور سواء الاخر في
حاله اتفاقه علي وعمر من التخدير الان هل
هناك مده معينه من عمليه استفاده سوف يتم
استمرار عمليه ما حتى وصول الى نقطه معينه
طبيه مثلا طبعا احنا اي طفل بعد عمليه
طويله يستفيق همم يعني يبدا بالافاقه بعد
العمليه هذا مؤشر جيد جدا جدا همم ولكن
احنا نحبد ان احنا نعطيهم الجرعات اللي هي
المهديه والمسكنه للالم حتى يعني همم
يمر عليهم اكثر من 12 ساعه او 24 ساعه همم
لانه العمليه كبيره ومؤلمه فهذا يؤثر كذلك
اذا كان في الم وما سيطرنا عليه ويؤثر على
المؤشرات الحيويه 24 ساعه هي الحاله
الطبيه الطبيعيه اللي همم الاستفاقه عمر
علي همم الاستفاق تمت الحمد لله نعم يعني
عندك حليب بدا يتحرك
الان هو بيتحرك لكن ايوه نتعامل مع ال همم
الحاله الان بان احنا نعطي له اللي هو
جرعات مناسبه بحيث انه نرجع وينام لانه
همم اهم شيء السيطره على قلم وعدم التوتر
في اول همم يعني 12 ساعه نقول من العمليه
الى 24 ساعه ومن ثم تدريجيا نخفف اللي هو
المسكنات
ايضا عمليه الاستفاده اذا كان لدي وقت 30
ثانيه هذه هي غرفه علي والان تم استفقته
بشكل تدريجي طبعا بخلاف اخيه عمر طبعا
هناك طبعا كما ذكرت الدكتوره هاله ان هناك
مسكنات تعطى للحاله علي في همم احتياجه لي
اذا اذا لزم الامر في احتياجه وكذلك
للمسكنات وكذلك لاستمرار عمليه تخدير
التدريجي ولكن هو استفاق بشكل كامل ويتم
متابعه حالته طبعا الامر المهم بالنسبه
للطفلين علي وعمر ان العلامات الحيويه
خلال الثلاث ساعات الماضيه بعد وصولهم
غرفته ما هي سليمه وصحيه وجيده وذلك من
خلال التقنيات التي يتم متابعتها والاجهزه
الطبيه الموجوده اضافه الى الكادر الطبيه
الموجود ايضا هنا في مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي في وزاره الحرس الوطني في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
الطبي الذي واكب هذه العمليه وساهم
بنجاحها وشكر خاص ايضا لك على مواكبه هذه
العمليه لاكثر من اثنتي عشره ساعه طيله
يعني الساعات الماضيه شكرا لك مراسل
العربيه هذه الصبيان على هذه الشهود
[موسيقى]
فوضى التسريبات التي اثارها الامير هاري
قبل اصدار كتابه سبير كانت العنوان
الرئيسي على كافه الصحف الغربيه بعض
الاعلام نقلها بتجرد والبعض الاخر علق
عليها بقسوه
[موسيقى]
لم تبدا الصحف الغربيه منذ ان اطلق الامير
هاري فوضى تسريبات التي رافقت طرحه كتابه
الذي يحكي قصه حياته المطربه مع العائله
المالكه وانفصاله عنها
الاعلام الغربي
اكثر اثاره من الحديث روايه ذوق الامير
هاري ان انفردت في تقرير يروي كيفيه ترميم
العلاقه بين الاخوه اي بين هاري وشقيقه
وتقول الشبكه الامريكيه وفق علماء النفس
ان في بعض الاحيان يكون الابتعاد عن
العلاقه مع الاخ او انهائها صعبا او مخرجا
لكن بعد القطيعه يشعر الشخص بتحسن اما
الامر الذي ادى الى القطيعه بين الاميرين
الشقيقين بحسب علماء النفس فهو ربما تكون
المنافسه بينهما او التمييز من قبل
العائله في يشعر احد الاشقاء بانه اقل
قيمه
واشنطن بوست اعتبرت ان الهجوم الشامله ضد
قصر باكينغهام من قبلها ريكان للترويج
لكتابه الجديد المكون من 400 صفحه في حين
تقول صحيفه الجارديا البريطانيه ان كتاب
ذو قيساكس الامير هاري هو الاكثر اثاره
وجدلا في كتب السير الذاتيه الملكيه وان
النجله الثاني للملكه تشارلز روى تفاصيل
المواجهه بين عائلته من دون ان تاخذ طرفا
بين الجانبين
اما لمون بالفرنسيه فكانت اكثر تشددا مع
هاري وميجا وكتبت بالعنوان العريض انه رغم
كلامهما واحلامهما لم يتمكنا من تحرير
نفسه ماء ووصفه الاميره الباحثه عن الحريه
بالمهوس
محاسن حضاره العربيه
في بريطانيا ايضا وفي اولي وجهه رسميه له
منذ اعتلاؤه العرش اختار الملك تشارلز
الثالث زياره فرنسا في السابع والعشرين من
مارتن مقبل وفقا لصحيفه ذا ترامز
البريطانيه واضافت الصحيفه ان جوله تشارلز
الثالث ستشمل زياره مجلسين نواب والشيوخ
الفرنسيين على امل ان تساعد في تحسين
العلاقات المتوتره بين البلدين بسبب قوارب
المهاجرين وخروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا واوضح اعلام
فرنسيسبقها سافر رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
الى باريس لكسر الجليد
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
متسببا بخسائر كبيره خطا مهندس صيانه وراء
تعطل نظام اشعارات الطيران في الولايات
المتحده
ايه والله تاجيل اللقاء بين المسؤولين
السوريين والاتراك دون تحديد موعد والاسد
يقول الاجتماع مشروب بالانسحاب
والحمد لله يعني تمت العمليه بنجاح
عمليه فصل التوام السيامي العراقيه علي
وعمر مشاهدينا مع هذا الخبر نختم التاسعه
الا ان اخبار العربيه مستمره كما كل ليله
والان الى 360 والزملاء راويه وطاهر راويه
وطاهر ماذا لديكم الليله مساء الخير ليال
طبعا الى موضوع جديد الوثائق السريه التي
وجدت في مكتب ومنزل الرئيس الامريكي
في هذه المعركه المستمره هناك اضافه الى
سوليدار رائد الاخبار